so there is a absurd amount of Papa
John's product placement in this movie
it actually started to work on me I
really wanted Papa John's towards the
halfway point of this movie but then I
realized it's Christmas Day what am I
going to do for once product placement
actually worked on me and I can't even
obtain what I want The Secret Life of
Walter Mitty is directed by Ben Stiller
and stars Ben Stiller it also stars
Kristen Wiig Sean Penn Adam Scott and
Shirley MacLaine this movies basically
about the biggest daydreamer out there
he will literally just freeze and just
start imagining these humongous worlds
someone will be talking to him and he'll
just zone out and we'll actually see
what he imagines he'll jump off a bridge
he'll save somebody from some burning
building or something and we get to see
all these interesting visual things that
he imagined in his mind because his real
life is so uninteresting to him that he
starts to use his imagination as a way
to make his life better in his mind at
least and Walter works for Life magazine
he processes negatives of photos that
photographers send to him Sean Penn is
this famed photographer who sends him
this group of negatives and he says
negative 25 is the absolute one that
must be on life's cover when Walter
can't find that negative he decides to
set out on an actual adventure that's
not in his mind to find Sean Penn and
figure out where this photograph is now
I've heard a lot of mixed things about
this movie it's really splitting the
board of people and I can see why
there's pros to this movie this cons to
it I don't think it's a terrible movie
in fact I actually enjoyed a fair amount
of it it does have some issues though
but let's start with the pros for one
this is a very good looking movie Ben
Stiller is actually a very good visual
director I was very impressed with his
unique camerawork in this movie I've
liked all the films that he's directed
Zoolander is actually one of my favorite
comedies believe it or not mer mad mer
bad and Tropic Thunder was hilarious too
this is his first venture into a film
that is slightly more serious though
even though it does definitely have an
air of comedy to it and this is a
sporadically funny movie and a lot of
the humor kind of revolves around this
cute PG like joke thing that they got
going between Ben Stiller and Kristen
Wiig in this movie sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't it's nice to see
Kristen Wiig actually play a character
though and not just this absurd thing
that she does a lot of times in movies
she's a funny actress I like her some
other things that I did like about this
movie were Sean Penn himself I thought
he
and something really cool to this movie
and he seemed just so laid-back he
really encapsulated what a photographer
is actually like because my father is a
photographer and he will sit sometimes
my dad will just sit in a location for
hours waiting for the perfect shot that
he wants to get and that's very much so
like Sean Penn in this movie and I
thought they really captured that very
well now this movie does have problems
though and one of the things that really
under my skin was the characters there
are some extremely corny and cheesy
cookie cutter characters in this movie
his sister in the film is just absurd
like she's not like any person on the
face since birth I really did not buy
her as a character but largely Adam
Scott's character he was so fake and
unrealistic and I did not buy him one
bit his character wasn't funny he just
felt very misused and out of place in
this movie he was definitely the big a
hole of the movie and that's the whole
thing and you're supposed to have this
scene where you hate him so much but
it's scene after scene of that and there
were a lot of cliched moments too like
where one character visits the house of
a girl he likes
and I was like they're gonna do the
boyfriend cliche or there's going to be
a guy there it's going to be cliche sure
enough you open the door and there's the
guy's face and it's like yep there it is
and I knew that was coming a mile away
and certain scenes towards the end of
the film you can just predict how
everything is going to happen because
there are so many cliches in this movie
that really brought it down in my
opinion there are certain times in the
first act of the film where he's having
all these imaginative visions that it
didn't really fit in and I understand I
can't really say that it's totally
inconsistent because obviously when
you're having a character sitting down
on a bench in one scene and all of a
sudden he's literally jumping off a
bridge for no reason that is totally
inconsistent but that's kind of the
point of it but it was kind of jarring
and not as funny as I think they thought
it was once he sets out on his adventure
though I did have a lot of fun with the
movie and as I said it looks great there
are some stupid parts to it though like
throughout the entire film a phone
customer service agent from eHarmony
continues to call Ben Stiller like on
his personal phone just a chitchat and
like that would never happen ever it has
a point in the movie yes but it just
would never it would never happen
also for some reason the title of this
movie in the opening titles of the movie
appears twice they show it twice and it
seemed like maybe they thought it was
too small and hidden from your average
audience member the first time they show
the title so in the next scene they show
it again really big and I was like yeah
the first time why are we seeing the
title twice tiny nitpick but kind of
weird at the same time there was one
scene in this movie that some people may
think was just so outrageous that they
might hate it he has this imagination
that he's in a film that has recently
happened a few years ago I won't spoil
what the movie is and the audacity that
scene actually made me laugh because at
first I was like what is this and then
it got really hilarious for some reason
because I was like that actually takes
some balls to do a scene like that
overall I did enjoy the film for the
experience I think it's a very
good-looking movie I think it can be
entertaining for a lot of people but it
does have a lot of flaws with a script
and the characters I'm gonna give it a
b-minus so guys thank you very much for
watching this I will have my best and
worst of the Year videos up very soon
thanks very much guys and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes